the city is dying
as sickness spreads throughout the
streets a ruthless Baron rules with an
iron fist bent on achieving his twisted
vision of progress at any cost
yet as disease and suffering spread so
too does a fierce anger this is a city
on the brink of chaos with no Saviour to
be found because for the only one who
save us not being found is what he does
best
hey just waking up
in theif the next game from the studio
behind Deus Ex Human Revolution you our
Garrett the master thief
I thought both you were there and had
been killed after losing your protege
and your memory you've returned to find
yourself the most wanted man in the city
hunted by the brutal thief-taker general
you'll need to use all the talents of
the master thief to find the truth
before your enemies find you
in the world of thief nothing is out of
bounds and nothing is out of reach
planning your heist carefully choosing
which path you take to reach your
objective
steal everything you desire using any
method you choose and use your tools and
every element of your environment to
outwit or eliminate anyone who stands
between you and your prize
the shadows are your only Ally use them
to move through the city undetected but
take great care to remain hidden from
the eyes of your enemies
your bow can be used in a variety of
ways using a number of different arrow
titles it's both a powerful weapon and a
versatile tool
you can choose to kill or complete the
entire game without taking a single life
employing non-lethal arrow types and
using your blackjack for silent stealthy
non-lethal takedowns use the cover of
night to explore the city streets at
your own pace infiltrating the homes
businesses and lives of the local people
greed is rampant and clients who desire
your services pay well the extra coin
can be exchanged for additional
equipment upgrades supplies and new
tools as you progress through the game
you'll also unlock new abilities to aid
you on your journey
use the focus ability to reveal the
valuable objects and hidden secrets that
surround you and to swiftly break into
secure passages and strong boxes
the city conceals countless treasures
and mysteries that have remained hidden
for centuries waiting to be uncovered by
those who know where and how to look but
remember even with finely honed skills
and all the right equipment not every
heist goes according to plan sometimes
there are always multiple ways to
execute the perfect heist so choose your
approach wisely
play is a predator using your arsenal to
strike fiercely from the shadows
or choose to play as a ghost using your
abilities to silently infiltrate steal
everything you find and disappear into
the night with no one realizing you are
ever there use whatever means you must
to get in and get out and above all
evade capture steal priceless objects
and store the most valuable items in
your hideout high above the safe streets
just remember
like obstacles and challenges lie around
every corner of the city
as do your enemies whether they belong
to the Barons watch or are something far
dangerous
become Garrett
the shadows
we come
the master thief
you